[Music]
welcome back to care for boys we are
indeed very careful boys so today we
want to talk about i mean dude a lot of
news today the inflation numbers just
came out it's looking rough stocks just
slid big time gas prices are [ __ ]
insane like worldwide but especially in
the united states at least for us
because we are the united states and so
we are looking only at ourselves um but
yeah i wanted to talk about like when
were you
the brokest that you've ever been and
you know how did you rise above
still going through it i'm already yeah
you'll be both i'm trying to hang out
with anthony lee so i can get richer
that's all smart i'm trying to just said
i'm still going through it no no you're
you're pretty rich in my eyes i think
nick's rich in maya
right before i moved here from cal or
from arizona i was working burger king
and best buy both full time but i was
living in an apartment out in chandler
the rent was crazy expensive what was
your rent
i was about to say crazy expensive for
us but when you think about it so we had
it was 1200 bucks split by three people
um it wasn't a nice part in chandler
it's like a it was called like a luxury
apartment so we have like nice floors at
a big room big like closet but
my part was it was i think we were
splitting it right so it's 12. so i
think each 400 bucks or whatever like
that right but my paychecks from best
buy working 40 hours a week we're like
520 bucks that's how like low i was
getting paid right so it's like almost
all of my money so i was just eating
burger king every single day every
single day like the last two weeks
before i moved here
and then towards that time my friends
were car hopping so they were going to
cars you know checking if it was open if
it was open you take all the [ __ ] out
what was like the big most common thing
they found usually so the comet so we
were next to a school called the
conservatory recording arts so people
used to have their backpacks full of
like macbooks um they sold you an
interface and or they didn't sell you
when you signed up for the school you
got an interface and a microphone which
were expensive so they would get that
and then they would go and sell it right
and like i would think off of each
backpack because they weren't trying to
like you know make the cell like go long
right so they would sell it for like oh
600 bucks or something like that right
but it's like a brand new mac and [ __ ]
like that but
it was all the time you're trying to
fence it as they said yeah so like
towards the end like i still remember
being super broke i went to a walmart
with like four bucks
and bought a bunch of ramen because i
didn't want to eat burger king anymore
right and just like being like [ __ ] and
i remember texting my friend like yo let
me know next time you go car hopping
because i think i think i'm gonna go
because i was getting sick like they
were
everybody had money except me but i was
the only one like doing everything right
like i had a job everybody else was like
[ __ ] don't punish for that yeah it
was kind of like weird i always thought
like i was like i got called dad right i
had the guy i was a guy at the recording
studio so everybody came to me i'd
record everybody i had two jobs no
walmart and burger king no best buy
burger best buy in burger king and did
you ever go car hopping i didn't luckily
i didn't so i almost did i i mean i got
to that point for the cars luckily for
the cars that would have stole so much
[ __ ] never did you never pull any best
buy scams no because i will say this
right now if you try to steal from best
buy you will get caught is that right
yeah everyone i know you will get caught
i mean because i my last job at best buy
because i worked there for a long time
was asset protection so i was a guy with
the yellow shirt up front
and you know people would steal and you
can get away with it but like people get
cocky and they keep coming back to try
and steal [ __ ] and all it takes is like
for me to remember be like oh this guy
looks familiar and then that was a cool
job when you did get gets a cat so what
do you say if you see a guy walking in
that normally can't be there because he
stole [ __ ] last time you're the guy
that's your job to be like hey yeah so
if someone comes in and i we've already
kicked him out i was the guy that had to
get in front of him and be like yo get
the [ __ ] out dude my buddy stole so much
[ __ ] at best buy
but then he didn't steal it like steal
it like a like a regular thief
what he did was i remember we walked in
and i was looking for like [ __ ] world
of warcraft for some game right this guy
goes to the tv section
opens up the tv
walks it up to the return section and he
goes can i return this and they go do
you have a receipt and he goes no and
they're like you got to get the receipt
and goes i think it's in the car and he
walked out with the tv what the [ __ ]
that was actually a big thing and i
remember when i worked in uh right
before i moved out here i was working at
the best buy fiesta mall people were
doing that
and i was just sitting there with my
world of warcraft like like the [ __ ] did
you just do
dude i worked at best buy like in
[ __ ] 2006 or some [ __ ]
and one of the things we had to deal
with the most was [ __ ] magicians
because they're coming in
they're coming in putting blankets on
top of tvs and they're pulling up the
[ __ ] tv then we see the mothers were
like
where the [ __ ] did the tv go dude
it was fun catching people still though
i will say that that [ __ ] was fun you
caught somebody oh i've cut i caught i
remember my first month
there because i was any magicians this
[ __ ]
i'm on the camera like trying to catch
people i caught more than they've had
caught in like two months in my like my
first month there but i thought that
[ __ ] was sick right and then you catch
them and then you get to go confront
them about are you allowed to like put
hands on them no uh they always say like
i don't wanna like i won't call out a
store but every store says like where
you live if it gets to a point where you
contact them like the cameras won't work
that day
my boy i had a
bro of definitely a bro right and he
lived in
in the boston massachusetts area the
massholes uh region
and uh he he he super cut
an lp prevention video you know loss
prevention yeah
uh like greatest hits video you did a
compilation of him tackling dude
so it just depends on where you live
yeah
he put it to like [ __ ] i don't know some
shitty rock music
and then it's like it's like a guy
walking into the [ __ ] tv and then he
just is grabbing him by the [ __ ]
waist and just like takes them all the
way down
dude people people get cocky man that
thing that joe's talking about literally
was a thing people would come in with
the big carts put tvs on and literally
just walk out yeah just no fear it was
crazy but when you steal [ __ ] you do
kind of have to have no fear though you
know i mean you have to that's how you
get away with it right yeah yeah that's
that's the best way to do it people
imagine to do with a trench coat and
he's looking nice left and right and
it's another trap something and he puts
it in it's amateur hour yeah the real
people are the ones you got to act like
you're supposed to be doing that oh yeah
eventually the magicians got so good
that we were just like we had to search
people for blankets at the door
and white gloves shut the [ __ ] up no
blankets
it's like what are you doing with these
uh these bicycle cards and these red
balls huh
if there's a dude with white gloves and
a top hat you're [ __ ] looking at them
you're following them all over the store
bunny in your hat's okay but no stealing
well because the key was if the blanket
was big enough to get over the object it
was going to disappear
so we were like dude we have to crack
down this bike any refrigerators they
stole no i didn't never saw it i heard
about it but i never saw it you know the
sick uh sam's club had it's not stealing
but uh sam's club had this thing with
their major electronics where uh
you could return it
whenever ever like whenever like it
wasn't one year wasn't 30 days it was
whenever and it had enough of insurance
and a warranty policy so you could like
buy a tv and then three years later when
the newest tv tech came out you can come
out with your old ass tv and return it
even i think without a receipt that's
baller like on this i remember super
bowl every every year on the super bowl
is the highest sales for tvs at best buy
and then the day after the super bowl is
the highest return rate on tv for best
buy because when they have parties
they'll buy the tv just for the super
bowl and then they'll come back that's
kind of tired because they didn't have
their stocking fees but now they do
because i just returned something a
couple weeks ago i was like what the
[ __ ] is this how's the recycling it's
like 15 or some [ __ ] oh yeah
my friend who worked at best buy did a
scam with when people returned tvs they
did something where they would mark it
as like because you know i get sent to
the refurbishing center or open box yeah
they did something with that where like
it on paper it had been sent back but
really they just like gave it to a
friend to hold that happened at the
store my first store when i worked out
here the guy the the main guy in the
back was doing that with all appliances
so he was supposedly sending appliances
to somewhere but he was just sending him
to his house and then he would resell
him yeah whoa
that's that was that was the racket but
he got caught he got caught yeah
that's why i never stole from best buy
and that's why i was like i'm about to
distill out these cars because we can
just run away and it's best by known for
that it's like they'll break your
[ __ ] legs
tell me so they can dig off to your
family and [ __ ] like that it's like you
look out your window and you see the
blue shirt and the caddies are like oh
geek squad is in the van and he's
turning off the [ __ ] electricity at
your house and [ __ ] they're like go team
go i would rather take my own life than
allow them to take my life
not the blue shirts man dude because the
geek swap doesn't [ __ ] around dude you
know you watch out for best buy they put
circuit city out of [ __ ] business
they kill those [ __ ] and radio
shots they'll be [ __ ] headphone jacks
down your throat
they don't [ __ ] around at all
hey on the uh on the car hopping tip i
know you didn't go now but like um if
you can answer this like on average uh
like how often do people leave their
cars unlocked uh from in arizona so like
i never actually did it right but i did
a couple times i was like the driver
right so like i would drive allegedly
this is where the supreme court goes you
did it yeah
you'd be surprised how much people do it
because even nowadays sometimes i'll
just forget to lock my car and i'll get
to my car and i'm like oh [ __ ] there was
a girl like a neighbor of our building
where my studios were at she left her
car unlocked windowed down
a guy came took her purse
uh
and uh
her gun today's video is brought to you
by babel
all right so i went to mexico last year
right and
um i was really like able to communicate
with a lot of people because of how much
spanish i just heard growing up here in
la and that really got me to think like
man
i want to learn espanol
in a major way but i ain't got like much
time to do this so good thing babel came
to the rescue
yeah because babel is awesome because it
only takes 10 minutes to learn a lesson
so they make it very digestible
especially if you got like 80d like me
then you're always like anything that
you're doing is competing with porno
and porno usually wins yep but in
between the portals you could do a
10-minute lesson especially when they
designed their program based off ai and
they got 150 language experts
it really makes it easy for you to learn
and you can start understanding foreign
pornos when you learn um because now you
can understand the in-depth personal
stories that go behind the characters
and that's always the best part of the
porno anyway yeah because they are like
14 different languages like our spanish
pornos now i understand french
german german all kinds so special and
also babel got the special speech
recognition technology which helps you
with pronunciation because sometimes if
you just practice in isolation yeah you
might get there and you've been
practicing practicing it the wrong way
the whole time i know because like what
if you're just practicing from the
portal and you're like idiots meow and
then you're like oh what dude you sound
like
somebody that's having sex yeah and
they're like no you got to say right and
then you say it inside babel and then
the babble is like no you you must do it
this way yeah or if you call someone a
putai the whole time they're like no you
do really anger someone and say
they're like oh
i don't think babel teaches you slang
but you get what i'm trying to say right
now you can save up to 60 off your
subscription when you go to babel.com
off the record that's babble.com off the
record for up to 60 off your
subscription babble language for life
wow
when my friend stole the gun that was
the biggest trip because like we were
sitting there and then we're just like
damn like it was a big ass ar-15 and we
were just like i'd be scared to like
steal a gun yeah yeah it was it was a
mission it was a mission to sell it i
would say that because the cop when the
police hear that someone stole your gun
they're going to really look for you
yeah perseverance then you got to like
know about [ __ ] scratching off the
[ __ ] you guys you guys have rain
cameras you don't sell it to normal
people so like we sold it to other
people that were like
a group of people the rain cameras
because if you if you look on the app
and like the the neighborhood feed the
community half of it
half of it is people um capturing people
going into their car
like that's most of them people going
there rifling through [ __ ] like if you
have a truck they're going through
you're trying to look for tools or
something yeah my dad's [ __ ] my dad
got that part of the truck what's it
called the door on the back
the door on the back on the back he got
that [ __ ] stolen one so remember
the whole door i remember we came back
and like we're like i'm like looking at
the truck i'm like that's a little weird
yeah the tailgate's worth a lot wait
what the [ __ ] it's like we're in the
back of my truck so it was just like but
that was like the rice rock it is you
remember the rice rocket age it's like
you'll go into the gym with your [ __ ]
lowered honda quarter with your [ __ ]
lip kit and your rims and all that
[ __ ] with the radio and your
subwoofer in the back going to the gym
you come out an hour later and it's
stripped
like how the [ __ ] sometimes it's really
odd parts because i had friends that
used to steal orders for
like backyard mechanics and they would
take stupid things that just really like
uh like the the little rubber strip in
the water channel of a civic like stupid
very specific yeah really specific dude
i went to a pawn shop one time i saw a
[ __ ] truck truck tailgate and i was
like son of a [ __ ]
[Laughter]
next to a bunch of magicians blankets
various sizes big sizes those are the
most expensive ones
52 inch size way more inventory that way
i'm surprised you you never went to
steal food because i know a lot of
people when they're broke they would
just go steal food you actually bought
food i tried to steal once food and like
i saw the guy because i'm very observant
and i saw like the guy that was working
was watching us
so then did you go in with like 20 kids
because they're always watching like
[ __ ] 50 kids that come up after
school they're like they're gonna go to
the candy section and jack some [ __ ] and
then 10 year olds are like why you
following me but how how old were you at
the time uh 20. was smashing grabs
happening yet no not with the no with
the car car hopping yeah i was 20.
because i feel like even at 20 and
especially if you got two jobs right at
that point well obviously it's a shame
and humility thing you got to get
through but i feel like it's easier to
ask enough people for food and receive
it
than to like steal you know what i'm
saying because if you're not like
straight up like homeless and smelly or
like a bunch of things like that it's
actually pretty
unassuming for like a uh a citizen but
hey i'm so sorry i'm running into some
trouble you think you helped me out i
talked to one because i did a trolling
video years ago with one and he was a
real home he was a real panhandler and
he was telling me he makes like
two fifty to three dollars a day
wow that's a lot yeah you know just just
asking for change yeah just asking for
change they're they they have that's a
whole racket hustle out here right it's
like
there's there's a people that bring out
their [ __ ] kids and stuff like that
but then like once they're done with
their shift they go back to their bmw
yeah that happened on arizona once right
there was a guy on right off the freeway
off of chandler right and he was there
all the time like for years and years
and i remember it was all over the news
because someone followed him
and they had noticed that in his bag i
guess they saw like a little sliver and
they thought it was like a laptop but it
was so after he got all this money he
went into best buy and was like paying
geek squad to fix his laptop and then
like followed him he had a [ __ ] house
and all this type of [ __ ] but he was
doing this [ __ ] for years because i grew
up going to school out there until
there's some panhandlers by where i live
and you see him all the time and they
actually live like up the block and we
have other family members that are like
oh i've seen that [ __ ] he has a
house across the street from me
dude i was at uh the the grocery store
the other day was like like 10 at night
right and then um these kids came up and
they're like sir can i wash your car and
i was like what and then i was like dude
how old are you they were like [ __ ]
12 or 30. i didn't ask him i was like um
i'll talk to you after i get out so i
was like man that was kind of weird
where's where's the mom and all that
stuff and i was watching the mom was in
the car and her sons were just out like
washing windows and [ __ ] and i'm like
that actually is like
way different than just asking people
for money industries yeah right yeah so
then um yeah when i went back out i gave
them some cash and i was like you don't
have to wash my car but i was like yeah
man um yeah good work guys and i just
left cause i was like and then they're
like [ __ ] losers
what [ __ ] four eyes weirdo
is weird you didn't even we didn't even
watch your car we got this for free
right prescription but i'm thinking like
dude that sucks like you're what
12 years old or whatever and then your
mom is just telling you to go [ __ ]
gas there's kids selling candy too
sometimes yeah and like oh it's for my
softball team and you're like we know
it's time for you you know when i was um
i'll take two after after college i was
doing a shitty sales job that i was like
unfortunately good at
uh where we literally go business and
business pretty much door to door and
like selling i'll wear a suit we were
selling sports tickets and [ __ ] right
so you were scalpers pretty much and it
got to a point where at the end of the
day if you like ran out of like blocks
of businesses to like walk into and like
do your whole sales pitch with your
business cards and all [ __ ] you'd be
like [ __ ] i still need to like uh you
would call ring the bell aka like hit
your quota for the day it's like i just
need to hit foot traffic so you go to
like a [ __ ] shopping mall in front of
a pavilion or something where you just
know a lot of people are gonna be out
there chances are people like the
dodgers or the clippers or whatever
[ __ ] tickets we have for that day
and you would just go up to people hey
you like this you like this you like
this and you ask them if they're like
not interested you bounce because
in sales you were taught it's a numbers
game yeah it's not even like how amazing
are it's just [ __ ] sp if you see 200
people today you're gonna get 12 sales
it was like one of those mathematical
guarantees that's so true so same thing
it's like i would rather
take my chances or at least i got into a
phase because i was also super broke
during that time take my chances of
being like if i just talk to as many
people as possible somebody's gonna want
what i got or give me something i need
whether i give a [ __ ] about if they're
into it or not somebody's gonna do it so
in the same light i just
i understand panhandling you know what i
mean it's like yeah totally yeah i don't
look down on it actually i just i feel
like yeah it's like you just got to do
it sometimes and you need it now so
people are like get go get a job it's
like they need the money right now it's
like day labor yeah and there are losers
out there like myself right [ __ ]
homeless guy little toby comes up to me
he's like yo dude like can you can you
give me some some food right i was like
hey man i can give you some money i can
really use some food i mean you know
what
yeah i'll get you some food
[ __ ] walk him over to the [ __ ]
fudd rock or johnny rockets or whatever
and little tell you who i'm talking
about he used to work there shut up dude
[Laughter]
yo why are you talking about my [ __ ]
sorry what were you saying anyways
he's like yo dude i want a burger i was
like man i'm being nice there i'm gonna
hook you with a burger he's like nah
dude but i got like i got a couple kids
i'm like blah blah blah right and he
like hustled me to get him three full
combos i spent like 35 bucks
and literally right out there i was like
number one i'm an idiot number two
this [ __ ] made me feel like i
never want to give money to a homeless
person again which is whack
but you know what he's like it's all
about touches it it's about volume
he's probably reading the size of the
sale
hey you know i watched a
he says no i walk away
it's a numbers game
he probably looks at me he's like i got
the sale
he's probably i'm particular
it's a bag just full of burgers
because most people would want to buy
food than give money to homeless people
because they're like i don't want her
which is why i was like yeah i'll go buy
you food i'm with it it's like end of
the night i usually have 50 75 burgers
guess what i sell to homeless people two
dollars a piece
are you [ __ ] kidding me i throw them
away how much did that cost me zero it's
called inventory [ __ ] it's
called sales and inventory i've
witnessed that before like i was with my
one of my dad's friends his name was
greg and we were driving back home and
there was like a homeless guy on the
side right off the freeway
so he runs on his window and his science
is like hungry all that type of stuff
and he rolls down the window and he's
like yeah i'm hungry he's like all right
well if you wait here i'll i'll go get
you food nah can you just get some like
money he's like no if you're hungry i'll
go i'll go buy you food
nah it's all good they want yeah they
want other [ __ ] yeah that's why uh i
think for like my rule is like i don't i
honestly don't give homeless people
money but i'll tip the [ __ ] out of a
cleaning lady i'll tip the [ __ ] i have
someone wash my car yeah i'll tip the
shout out
but they're basically
pretty much they're the same they're
struggling but they're [ __ ]
floating at least yeah yeah but they're
they still have the dignity to like try
to [ __ ] make it and i love that about
that and they're providing something
that you didn't need and you're not
doing it to patronize them yeah yeah i
mean the homeless public people in la
they're contributing to the uh community
culture
it's la it's not l.a without homeless
people style you know what i mean
i remember straight up um this is like
man before youtube anything like me and
my
my chick we moved to l.a together
powderies
oh man 23. and i remember i i joined
this um
i joined this gay men's club service
yeah gaming thank you very much we're
stuck into his cox
but i joined this this temp service and
then i got placed at this at this
company which is like this high-rise in
downtown l.a that i always talk about
that i worked at but there was like a
two month
limbo period where
i didn't get paid yet for some reason
because the p the t they have to pay the
agency the agency pays you right so it
was like 90 days or some [ __ ] and so i'm
working at this place like in earnest
all week no matter what like pursuit of
happiness right yeah and then i'm
waiting for the check to ever come and
then um there was a day where
i basically just had my savings account
and like um i had it i had like just to
pay rent and all the electricity all
that stuff and then one of the checks
bounces and my account overdrafts like
four times so it's like that's a good 36
dollar charge like four times in a row
and so it's just like oh [ __ ] um and
then i remember
being in a target with my chick and my
card that got declined so i that was
when it was it was getting it was
getting like bounced back and [ __ ] i
remember being like
i remember she had to like ask her dad
for money and i remember the shame that
i had at the time because my family just
been through through 2008
so they were not an option
so it was like
man i really am [ __ ] right now um and
i remember telling her i remember
hugging her that night and telling her
this will never happen again
and like after that it was just happened
two more times
it just kept on happening you had to
break over there
kept happening and then it kept
happening and then it just happened
again last week
[Laughter]
no but but i remember like specifically
telling me i'll never this will never
happen again and then my mindset changes
like you know you know that whole thing
too where you're not getting paid for
like two months but you're not exactly
bitching at anyone either you're being
polite because you don't want to you
know that other people are working too
and like they're the small fish at their
company and you don't want to make them
have a bad day but sometimes you have to
stand up for yourself 100 you know what
i mean yeah and that's what i really
learned through that experience was like
no no
i'm not going to be the guy who doesn't
get paid because i'm going to be loud
and annoying until you [ __ ] pay me
yeah you know what i mean and then the
you know it'll be the guy who has
learned that lesson i just learned um
who who's gonna eat the [ __ ] shitty
taco and like next week because this
week i am getting [ __ ] paige
and for whatever reason that dance that
they do is very odd but yeah it was it's
targeted towards feeding the noisy
people so i just became a way noisier
person and that helped me in life after
that
standing up for myself right like like
having the balls to stand for myself in
other situations too after that like
where finances were involved where it's
like maybe i wouldn't have gotten
something that i ended up getting or
maybe i got way more than i would have
gotten because i negotiated better for
myself because from that moment forward
it really was just a mindset shift that
i embraced it was like that i will never
go through this again because it's gonna
be on you yeah so you're gonna have to
suffer for me it's not like i'm waiting
for the people that you don't even
remember
if you're compliant then they'll keep
you waiting forever exactly they'll
forget about you especially when it
comes to money dude yeah oh dude it's
like people that owe you money yeah like
if you just if you just i don't want to
bug them oh dude you want to be a
hollywood writer guess what [ __ ]
net 90's nothing compared to being a
[ __ ] writer in l.a
i hate hearing that nine days if you
passing that sexy i'm like [ __ ] off yeah
dude net 90 but the dude we're talking
about you're a writer now right you got
paid up front maybe minuscule compared
to what the revenue is then you get a
piece of that and you got to wait a year
maybe holy [ __ ] mad
like net 365 [ __ ]
essentially and then trickle and then
trickle and then trickle so yeah you
have to it's a whole another mental game
too i hate it when somebody owes you
money and the next time you see them
they got like new clothes yeah oh the
best that's me
i was homeless when i was 15 for a year
oh time's up no we're talking about no
no hey bart stand up bart stand up i was
homeless when i was 15 for a year bart
stand up yeah yeah
no no please please please
i don't know what you're saying no
please please let joe continue yeah
that's okay cool
well i thought the joke was i say a
significant statement he cuts it oh do
you have nothing oh are you doing that
no it's true it's actually i'm actually
interested really hear about it maybe
for another time yeah let's not let's
not leave alex hanging because he's the
only one who's like he's like i was
broke and then we're all like let's talk
about others no no because this was
supposed to be a broke episode but yeah
alex story was so good and then all and
we just kind of drifted off into like
we're not supporting him by giving him
our broke story i'm like damn i'm the
only broke [ __ ] in here
no we're all broke
in different ways like overdrafting [ __ ]
bro i remember like literally like being
like all right i know overdraft fees are
35 bucks right and if i know that as
long as i have like two bucks if i buy
something it'll take like three days for
an overdraft fee to come in as long as
like within like two days i put my
enough money in i don't know
but there are so many times where i like
knew like all right i just need to do
this and just i have to subtract 35
bucks for my next paycheck right wow so
i used to do that so many times being
like [ __ ] all right this is gonna be
[ __ ] 70 bucks off my next paycheck
but i need this [ __ ] right now so i
would go and buy [ __ ] knowing that i was
gonna have overdraft fees and just being
like i'm gonna have to pay this off my
check but then it's also another 70
[ __ ] i did that for so long too that
i finally had to be like i need to
change something so i went to the bank
and i was like uh do the overdraft
protection where am i saying if i'm
about to overdraft yeah um decline the
car i was too scared because i needed
that i had to i needed that that's why i
overdrafted so many times because i was
in that situation too and then finally i
was like yo i'd rather
not be able to afford that moment and
then just deal with the consequence of
the moment versus like pretend i had
another 35 bucks my friend's mom worked
at wells fargo too and she like she i
remember one time she saved me because i
went in there she's like all right i'll
give you i'll take these overdraft fees
away and i'll give you back like six of
them
oh [ __ ] so she gave me so much money
because she was like the head of her did
she put a blanket over the screen
make it disappear she'll get you a tv
too while you're right she was like we
can just put overdraft fees on and i
still remember at that point i was like
no i'll be good but i just knew in my
head i was like i can't because i know
at some point i'm gonna have no money
again
and i'm gonna have to be able to spend
like for food or some [ __ ] like that so
i lived in overdraft fees for a long
time yeah that's a hard space to exist
you could always go back to burger king
dude they paid me [ __ ] they were i was
getting those chicken sandwiches are
pretty amazing i moved i was making 7.75
an hour i was working full time i was
doing five to one and then at best buy
they were paying me 8.25 i was working 2
to 10 p.m
but you know what i respect overall you
were [ __ ] working bro yeah like a lot
of people are just broke and they're
just like i have no money but they're
not [ __ ] worried the hardest thing is
i was working so much and i had no money
and all my friends who were just [ __ ]
gangbangers and [ __ ] thugs just have
money all the time but they're not on jk
news the [ __ ] don't know but man i was
just they're hella rich
you